getroffen
er liebt es die idylle zu zerstören ein
provokateur dieser tomi ungerer mit
zeichenstift und beißendem spott
verarbeitet er bis heute alles was ihn
umtreibt
viel schicksalhaftes gab es in seinen 84
lebensjahren ein überlebender seiner
traumata ist er drei herzinfarkte krebs
überwunden
als er drei jahre ist stirbt sein vater
ein verlust bis heute 1940 er ist zehn
besetzen die deutschen das elsass
manisch zeichnet er alles auf
verarbeitet so allem negativen im leben
habe ich es habe ich benutzt als
treibstoff ob die hoffnungslosigkeit
auch die minderwertigkeitskomplex und so
weiter
das wird alles bei mir benützt unter den
nazis wird der französischsprachige tomi
gezwungen sich in kürzester zeit
anzupassen
es kommen die nazis und innerhalb sechs
monaten darf man kein wort französisch
mehr sprechen
man kann sogar verhaftet werden für
einen einfachen bonjour oder bon soir
oder maxi verboten
der krieg die bedrohung die von ihm
ausgeht die kriegsfolgen
motive die in thomasberg präsent bleiben
werden
hin und hergerissen zwischen zwei
nationen lernt er früh toleranz ist eine
überlebensstrategie
die waren ganz nett ganz okay und auf
der französischen seite gab es genau so
nette menschen uns überall
doch schon der junge roma ist ein
aufmüpfiger aus dem französischen
gymnasium fliegt er hochkant ohne abitur
ohne schulabschluss wie geht die
geschichte weiter
tommy unna mit 25 jahren will es wissen
er wagt den sprung über den großen teich
versucht sich als zeichner in new york
city innerhalb eineinhalb jahr habe ich
mein erstes buch ist erschienen und ab
sofort einen preis gekriegt das zweite
buch auch wieder ein preis und das ging
alles los
amerika liebt tomi ungerers kinderbücher
doch auch hier immer wieder bricht er
die idylle realistisch auf düster ist
die stimmung furchteinflößend gibt es
immer angst möglichkeiten aber die
kinder überwinden immer ihre angst die
kindern in meinen büchern aber nie an
diesen begriff billigten den kindern
schon früh beibringen dass man alles
überwinden kann
no matter what you can do du kannst es
schaffen
nach dem steilen aufstieg in den usa
kommt in den sechzigerjahren der absturz
der us amerika kritische und
antirassistische arbeiten irritieren die
amerikaner und seine pornografischen
bilder erst die verstören komplett für
das prüde amerika kinderbücher und
erotik sein werk verschwindet aus den
läden
das enfant terrible hat es zu weit
getrieben zurück nach europa in irland
findet er mitte der 70er jahre eine neue
heimat
bei 1
das größte moment in meinem leben war
nach dem krieg wie ich das ozean
entdeckt habe und das muss ich haben
deshalb lebe ich da ich bin da direkt
auf die klippen und mein gott die stürme
die wir haben also das ist für mich
zählen futter 40 jahre später zeigte uns
nun eine auswahl aus seinem riesigen
schaffen dass schweiz ist die luft zu
drucken
das sieht wie schwach aus soll das
schamhaar zigaretten
inkognito heißt die ausstellung im
kunsthaus zürich die jetzt überraschende
einblicke in die arbeit des
unverbesserlichen provokateurs gibt
150 bücher weiß thomas pfefferer auf und
das erfolgreichste ein liederbuch
darin finden wir es sein lebensmotto
kein mensch kann sie wissen keine jäger
erschießen mit pulver und 3 die gedanken
sind frei